Good evening guys,
this is a video about studying multiple
foreign languages and how you can switch
between those different languages
without getting confused and mixed up.
A.
You've looked at my channel before.
You've seen that I've studied a number
of different foreign languages.
Maybe you've studied a number of
different foreign languages and maybe
you found it kind of confusing or maybe
you've found there's some overlap
between the language or you've crossed
wires between language.
Maybe it gets confusing when you study
more than one.
How do you keep them all inside your
head and be able to speak more than a
couple languages,
like five,
six,
seven languages?
How do you do it?
Well,
keep in mind,
I'm talking from the point of view of
someone who has studied all these
foreign languages.
As an adult,
I didn't learn any foreign language or
second language as a kid.
I was raised monolingual just speaking
English.
So this is from that point of view of
learning as an adult.
Someone who learned that as a kid might
be different to keep that in mind.
Um,
okay.
So basically there are three things.
I'll start with the first one.
I think you really need to refine your
pronunciation for each of the languages
you really need to get specific with
your,
uh,
with the distinctions you make in the
phonology,
so really look at all the different
sounds in each language and get them as,
as specific and as precise as possible
because I think a lot of what causes
crossover between different languages is
that you were using the same phonology
or similar phonology for those languages
when a native speaker has a very
precise,
distinct phonology for that language.
So this is something that my theory on
this came from studying a few different
languages.
I studied Hebrew and Arabic,
which are quite related,
but the phonology isn't that similar.
The quite different.
But also I've studied French and I find
that I've had a lot more crossover
between French and Hebrew.
Then between Arabic and Hebrew,
even though French and Hebrew are not
related really a.
and that's because there are some
similar phonological sounds between
Hebrew in French that are,
that don't exist between Hebrew and
Arabic.
So that's caused some of the crossover
between them.
It's the phonology,
it's the similar phonology.
So in order to solve that problem,
I had to really get precise with my
phonology for French and for Hebrew,
I had to look at all the sounds,
look at exactly how to pronounce those
sounds that were causing the confusion.
So you can do that.
I mean,
when I say refine your pronunciation,
that's in general,
focus on studying your pronunciation and
improving it,
get some help from native speakers,
really focused on emulating native
speakers,
but also at a more advanced level of
teach you a little technique that,
uh,
that helps people take it to a more
native level or near native level.
The technique is this imagined that a
particular native speaker is actually
speaking through you.
It might sound strange,
but there you're kind of channeling a
certain person through your body and
they're speaking out your mouth.
Like when I speak French,
I imagined that Sarcowski,
the former president,
is speaking through me because he's
somebody that I modeled when I was
studying French.
I paid attention to his pronunciation
and tried to copy his intonation.
So when I speak French,
when I'm trying to get precise with my
pronunciation,
I imagined it's him speaking through me.
All right?
And when I speak Tagalog,
I imagine a certain Filipino person who
I know who speaks to,
I imagine that person is speaking
through me.
And by doing that you're really,
um,
your,
your brain is picking up on a lot of
very little subtle cues and the
pronunciation that you can't pick up on
consciously.
If you try to focus on all those little
differences,
you can't really do it,
but if you just focus on the whole
person,
your unconscious mind can pick up on all
those little fine tuned elements of the
pronunciation and help you out a lot.
So that's one thing.
It's one trick you can try a for getting
your pronunciation to a more authentic
level.
Okay?
So focus on the pronunciation.
That's my first piece of advice.
The second thing is 100 percent
commitment,
no half stepping,
100 percent commitment when you are
switching into the next language.
Okay?
So when you were moving from one
language into the other,
it's kind of like you are walking
through a doorway into another room.
If you enter the doorway and you just
stand in the doorway and try to speak
the other language of the other room,
you're going to retreat into the first
road.
You're going to go back into the other
language,
or you're going to get some crossover
between the two.
You'll find it hard to really move into
the second language.
So what you really need to do is just
make a firm decision,
okay,
now I'm switching into the other
language.
I'm not going back into the old one.
I'm walking through the doorway and I'm
closing the door behind me,
right?
So you're,
you're basically just completely
deciding,
I'm speaking this language now and not
the other.
You don't want to switch back and forth.
So you want to just lock the door behind
you.
Okay?
So it's really just about pushing
yourself and making a firm commitment.
And when you make that firm decision to
speak this one,
then it just motivates you and pushes
you forward and takes you into that zone
of that language.
Okay.
So that's the second thing is just that
100 percent decision.
Okay,
I'm going to speak French now.
I'm going to speak Arabic now and
completely cut off the language.
You were speaking a moment earlier.
All right,
so that's number two.
Number three is a little more abstract
and it's one that I don't use all that
often anymore,
but I used it.
I've tried it in the past and made use
of it when I needed it.
And it's like this,
you imagine a scene that you associate
with the language that you want to
speak.
So for example,
when I speak French,
I might imagine the scene on the patio
of a cafe in Paris,
right?
And imagine all of the subtle little,
the subtle little sensory cues that go
along with that,
like,
um,
the taste of wine at the smell of my,
my baguettes and all that kind stuff.
Um,
and hearing the ambiance around me,
hearing the French language spoken
around me,
so by doing that,
you,
you're creating a connection between the
language and that image so that whenever
you want to move into that,
that state in which you are speaking the
language well than you imagine that
image and that brings you into the zone
of that language.
Okay?
So that's something you can try.
Another example of it,
when I speak Hebrew,
I imagine the time I spent in Jerusalem
because that's a very vivid time for me
so I can bring myself back to that time.
Imagine the environment.
Imagine a certain situation I was in,
in that place where I can hear Hebrew
speakers and I see a different cultural
things that remind me of the Hebrew
language and all of that.
So all of those things are associations
that bring me back into the zone when I
was speaking Hebrew.
Well,
all of these pieces of advice,
that kind of abstract,
I wish I could be a bit more logical and
scientific in the tips I'm giving,
but when we're dealing with we're
dealing with switching from one language
to another.
We're we're dealing with switching into
different states and that kind of
requires you to take control of your
perception,
right?
It's not the same for everybody,
so if these tips don't really work for
you,
then you don't have to use them.
Of course.
Just think about similar types of
techniques and how you can control your
perception in a way that will take you
into that zone where you are speaking
the language well,
so a lot of it has to do with
associations and connections with that
language.
Another thing I should point out is that
the language is that you haven't spoken
recently are always going to fade a
little bit if you leave them in the
background,
right?
The ones that you can move into the most
easily are the ones you have used most
recently,
so don't expect to use one of these
techniques and be able to speak really
well and really,
really instantly in a language you
haven't spoken in five years,
uh,
you might be able to with the basics of
that language,
but you won't be at the level you were
at five years ago obviously because you,
you start to lose some of the language
gradually.
So just keep that in mind.
Uh,
it's also a matter of just keeping the
language fresh and keeping them a well
practiced.
You can't always do that with all of
them.
If you speak 10 languages,
you can't speak all 10 every day,
so you will always have some that are
more ready to go than others.
And the others are more waiting in the
background for you to retrieve them and
start to practice and,
and brush up on those languages.
And then there'll be in the forefront
end ready to get into the zone again.
Alright.
So that's all I've got to say about
that.
Hope that's clear.
Talk to you later.